what's going on John what's that what's
that what's up how are you really good
good to see you guys you gotta be
feeling good oh yeah I feel great yeah
you cut your hair yeah it's down do you
like it though because we don't
necessarily like the cut we don't think
the back looks very good do you think
that looks good
I mean it's grown in a little bit it's
got the taper going yeah there's a
little paper to it it's a New York thing
New York swag right it was good
New York swag Jim you wouldn't know
about that no I certainly wouldn't you
know you know you took all yours off it
looks good who would understand better
than Jim isn't a New York swag type of
guy we all know I'm from Jersey some
insurance my kind of guy I mean he just
keep shaving it so the greatest show how
do we took all yours off
uh I am very funny funny answer i watch
the tupac movie there's two bucks
he had the bald head with the goatee and
I was rocking it for a while like let me
try the ball hit with a goatee and I
loved it then I tried to trim my my
mustache and can I say [ __ ] it up yes
a [ __ ] we [ __ ] it up I'm just doing
this kind of got a war look isn't it
great no easier it's just I love having
like very little hair yeah it's so much
easier yeah it feels different no like
when you're like when your brother is
just such a foreign feeling right I
don't know that the bald head is new for
me so anyways did you like the Tupac
movie I heard like next thing I heard it
was really good then some people said
like they didn't like it I like I loved
it so I grew up on a super like my dad's
pastures and there might have a super
shelter and so a lot of it like a lot of
like old music like my dad just looked
at it all the secular music it wasn't
allowed in our house so when I watched
movies like Straight Outta Compton or
the Stupak moving so I learned things
about well the hip-hop that that most
people you know I already know right
so I actually learned a lot about the
guy that through this movie and a
developed sense of respect for well I
did it's funny I couldn't watch radar
movies and I was a kid are you the
oldest no I'm the third down from the
available see your mom and dad were just
strict about like what was in the house
language wise oh yeah dude it was bad
but we weren't a lot we weren't a lot we
did have cable TV we have cell phones
until I got senior year in high school
we were never allowed to spend the night
at people's houses growing up my parents
had the same there is no extra ten
o'clock nothing good happens so this is
my super shelter and then that's why I'm
such a wildlife now
catching up for all this should I missed
out on yeah that's what happens when
it's like this I think the preacher's
daughter like when she gets out it says
if you raise Li strict I mean you get
out you want to do something I what you
just said like most most guys at some
point in their lives like they grew up
around when we did like wanted to be
like Tupac in like 95 94 like you're
just like kind of catching up like I
dunno [ __ ] this guy was cool I could be
like oh [ __ ] now oh yeah it doesn't
unfortunately get you a lot more trouble
yeah HIV like to [ __ ] but it's kind of
fun to go back and learn stuff about
something that's already a completed
work or that's been there for twenty
year like that's kind of I love going
back in grabbing stuff my body weight I
have a canker sore garden and it's
[Music]
alright it just came off as I'm talking
about of course Tommy swab okay that's
biodegradable he's working cursor guard
yeah so it's a weird little thing that
you put on you I cut my mouth with my
mouth guard I sleep with a mouth guard
so put a sore my mouth from grinding
because I put this canker guard on it
okay the hell of a drug canker sore
thing and I know but it wound up but
it's biodegradable so it just kind of
dissolves and it just kind of came off
and I just finished it I'm glad talking
talking so but you do you relate to Jim
like handling his injuries like you
might in training or whatever like he
sometimes you know gets an injury from
his from his knee a mouth guard well I
don't know to say that would be a good
congratulations by the way
congratulations it was really weird
fight to watch because I like you and I
like DC and it was like heartbreaking to
watch him break down like that but I was
happy for you thank you because you know
it's like you went through a time where
things were [ __ ] up and now you came
back and you were great
yeah I do believe everyone loves a good
redemption story yeah and I was aware
that going into the fight and you know
leading up to the fight and just you
know probably do everything in my power
to be that that great comeback story and
and this is what it was it's been and
the support has been tremendous you know
just so many people writing me and
something about how just my story has
inspired them to just keep moving
forward and it's great to be looked at
as a person who is really hard to be
defeated by life did you did you really
because I thought he looks really good
like he looked much looser and he's
getting inside he was closing the
the distance really much better than I
think in the first fight at the end of
the first round I was looking at you
sitting there and you looked a little
bit like okay I'm going to fight now so
how did you feel at the end of that
first round after round you know
actually so I didn't warm up properly so
after the first round yeah Daniel Devlin
was doing a really good job in and he
was fighting a lot better than I
expected him to fight but my lungs were
opening up and you know any athlete
would know the feeling where it's like
we need to get that first sprint and how
you can't breathe and then after you
kind of warm up a little bit you can you
know you get your second win you can
move a little bit right that's what I
was going through after round one I
thought I had a great warm up but I
didn't focus enough in my lungs and so I
do that to round one I was like oh my
goodness like I just focusing on some
breathing exercises that I try to do so
I think that's what you saw you know
just that frantic look in my face
but after I got my breathing under
control I felt I got my lungs warmed up
I got back to being calm cool and
collected and just having fun out there
but yeah Daniel did he did a hell of a
job - he he he definitely was a lot
better than he used to be which which
makes me feel good about myself because
that beat a better version yeah after
almost two years off so so somebody said
about that how'd you feel about the
about his breakdown after the 504
interview he's you know crying I felt
bad from it at the end of the day there
is no mercy in combat and I mean I do
feel as if he would have won it would
have been a complete different energy it
would have been in your face I'm the
champ I told you you know I was the
greatest and I mean looking round - he
was starting to talk to me I've never
had anybody talk to me during a fight
before he started pointing his finger at
me and all you're missing and saying all
this [ __ ] during the fight so I mean he
was being arrogant just thinking that he
was going to win I can only imagine the
way he would have acted if you were to
actually won so um so yeah with that
being said I'm glad I'm glad that the
way that I handled the situation because
it definitely uh it's it's helped me
develop a lot of respect that I thought
you know was unsolved unsalvageable and
obviously it wasn't
the respect and the just the fan support
has been tremendous oh and I had
interviewed you on UFC unfiltered we
were talking about you possibly moving
up to heavyweight and you said like yeah
I kind of want to I've thought about it
but I want to make sure I picked the
right guy I don't want to go too heavy I
want to stay around 235 and then you
call out Brock Lesnar biggest moose ever
fight in the UFC what made you call out
it I mean that just because that's a
huge money fight yeah it's a big money
fight it's like I think I find uh I
think I was inspired by Conor McGregor
to be honest with you just dare and to
reach reach higher I mean me versus
Brock Lesnar is is someone equivalent to
Mayweather in McGregor I mean a lot of
people would assume that I would lose
that fight I mean Brock Lesnar is super
athletic he was a division 1 national
wrestling champion
yeah he's older but he's just a freak I
mean he's a rare talent and I don't know
what that betting odds would be on that
one and so it's just like it's like you
know what do the impossible you know be
the be the David and the deleted David
and fly obscuring just the same way you
know McGregor dares to compete against
Floyd Mayweather it's like you know what
if you come up short at least you have
more balls than most
the average American they even step in
there but I mean if you win just the
glory that comes with being a boy I'm a
whether or being a broccoli right you
know it's huge what weight do you walk
around that normally I walk around at
about 2:30 okay so you'd probably be
giving up 25 or 30 pounds to him when he
walks around out any fights sorry about
265 I would imagine he's a fool is about
275 oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah but he had
to fight at 260 235 yeah do you know
what is what is the likelihood of him
getting into an octagon is because like
a couple weeks ago is when they started
saying that he was going to start trying
to campaign for eligibility yeah and
then but like this weekend I was reading
that he's not doing that anymore and
he's just using it as bargaining so he
can stay with WWE interesting yeah I
don't really I haven't really looked at
the breathalyzer situation too much I
know that that once he and
the drug testing pool he would have to
complete six months of that right now
he's refusing to join in right okay cool
so I mean I'm not accusing him of being
on steroids or whatever I don't see why
you wouldn't sure start the process if
you were being a clean athlete but I
don't know what he's got know what's
going to happen with him but I know
Brooks a great businessman and I know he
knows this would be huge money and you
know I'm 40 pounds lighter than him so
I'm sure that just the thought of being
the first person to defeat me is really
you know it has to be running through
his mind in the payday so I'm sure the
fight except it's got to happen is just
going to be a matter of time so even
like let's say today he was like okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna jump into that pool
it's six months before he can even think
about having a fight right I see but can
he can you guys say he jumps in the pool
now can they at least book a fight and
go okay we're looking at February yeah I
would imagine they're they would start
from when the fight just the same way I
was promoting my last fight and while I
was still technically suspended so yeah
I'm sure they they could do that bro
were you afraid at one point that your
career was over
did I thought either you know
athletically you can still do it at that
point like I've just spiraled and I
can't get out of this you know I'm after
the hit and run two years ago I started
thinking man there is no coming back
from this I mean I'm not to get into it
but it was just it was just it was so
ugly it was such an ugly situation and I
just felt like I was an unforgivable
position and and then I you know I I
started getting talked to by mentors and
people just saying you know John there's
been so many athletes who's does so much
worse not to compare yourself and make
what you did any lighter but I mean
there's been so at least that that's
come back from terrible accusations or
whatever the allegations and so um
there's that what you did was a mistake
is you've been young having too much fun
it's not like you this malicious
terrible human being you know you're
just doing dumb [ __ ] and you got to snap
out of it and get back get back what's
yours and watching Anthony Johnson and
Daniel Cormier fight for my title and
hearing these types of things I just I
just thought man you know what I
need to be out there I started thinking
you know potential is the worst you know
to have talent and to not be using it
it's the worst and I was just like I'm
gonna I'm going to not only come back
but I'm going to come back in such a
triumphant way and just and try to live
the rest of my life better ultimately
because I mean I think that's that's the
real win in the whole situation is doing
the right things moving forward and so
uh so yeah I'd answer your question I
did think about quitting but um but
instead of actually putting like I think
a lot of people would do one thing when
times go over rough I decided just to be
on fire about life and about coming back
and making it better than ever and now
we're here is even a feeling like I'm
stand on top of the world again what's
hard to like when you use such a young
guy and like you've being considered
this greatest fighter on alright I mean
Tyson had a hard time with that I mean
when everything is all of a sudden
people like oh my god this is the
baddest man on the planet I mean it's
got to be difficult you have not given
to any temptation what did it because
you say it like you were raised without
any of this stuff yeah is even a thing
like at what point did you start to
become this party guy I think I think
just growing up kind of being a throwing
up kind of like we were definitely
underprivileged family and I think every
a lot of people me anyways I always had
this desire to be to be the cool guy
sure he wanted to be popular and stuff
like that and and you know I I became
cool you know I became cool and then
famous and rich and it's just like wow
you know it was not a life that I ever
expected to live and slowly but surely
it just became harder and harder to turn
down having a blast and you know I just
that's it really is I never got to have
fun like this before and now I just get
to do whatever I want yeah do whatever
you want you just you just find yourself
around a different reality than most
people ever get to experience and being
a small town kid who grew up simple
managed it was it was a good dream come
true but and now I see the danger in
that though and and and you know I'm
just I'm grateful for all the struggles
that I've been through but you were not
gonna let my life experience is so high
right now
you were not cool growing up
uh I mean I was pranking a tower okay so
I mean and you know what the reason why
I was a prom king was I I I wasn't like
I was when I said I grew up super
underprivileged or whatever but I was
the kid that was nice to everyone so you
know the kids and the special classes
you know I knew a few of them and I was
nice to them you know the nerdy kid over
there or the poor kid over there or
whatever like came with a disability I
knew their names I was friends with
everyone and so I had the people's vote
and say it was actually funny when I saw
myself on the ballot with all the
popular kids you know I was like how the
hell am I even up here I have to
surprise to everyone but I ended up
winning that and it just showed you know
you know just be nice to people be nice
to people you have tribute with respect
and it it won't go unnoticed do you feel
like you appreciate it more now because
like whenever you face losing something
or whenever something's taken away you
can't do it for a while it's stinks and
you're like this is what life would be
like if this was gone and now you have
it back and you want do you think you'll
look at a little bit differently now and
absolutely yeah my appreciation for it
for being the UFC lightweight champion
has grown tremendously at one point I
thought that I just couldn't lose and
and I just thought I was designed to win
and I can do it of our one still go out
there and win and I just took it all for
granted and now I realize that I you
know I actually it's possible to be
defeated and and that the window is
actually not as big as I thought it was
and and so that I need to do all the
right things to to look myself in the
mirror every night and know that I'm
giving myself the best chances to be
absolute legend of the sport and it
feels good to dare to be great and
actually put your true best self forward
and that that's who I am today and
that's what I'm trying to do today
what's the conversation like with Dana
White when you have to pull out of a big
advertised fight three days before the
fight because of the because of the the
drug test that was after the riot so I
was on imagine he's gotta because I
remember that press conference and he's
like he's beat red when he's doing a
press conference because he's just found
out that this big because I mean you
know it's not a Floyd Mayweather fight
they say money
a million five and it is business and
like now and he doesn't know at that
time there was other stuff going on UFC
200 was projected to be the biggest
fight in MMA history I was the headline
of it and threw it ain't a supplement
she's a total mistake you know the fight
was canceled and they know I was really
really upset said a lot of things that
I'm sure he regrets and and there really
wasn't much conversation between him and
I know he doesn't like call you up and
rip your head off and no no no I know I
mean he definitely expressed to my team
that he was disappointed in the way
things happening and tried to put it try
to explain it to us from his point of
view saying you know John Woodson is
there's a lot of sponsors and there's a
lot of people who invest in these UFC
events going down and when when the main
event drops out you know there's
millions of dollars lost and so we got
that and I was gonna super apologize
about it but at the same time it was
true mistake and we live when we learned
yeah yeah yeah I mean yeah there was to
come from like to come from a series of
stuff that you were correcting right for
then that mistake to just happen right
at that time it was I think it was odd
it was terrible yeah because you know
look I said two years ago I was actually
getting in some and some real trouble
like legal trouble I was living young
wild and free a little too free and
almost lost I don't was it free yeah
wasn't bring actually so uh yeah like
that was all two years ago and then I
did a lot of things to get back to being
able to fight at UFC 200 a year ago and
then to take a male enhancement pill
that was designed for you know your
private life sure to have that you know
be tested in and to find out it was a
tainted supplement it was like you know
no none of the fans really care to get
into the court case and like in like in
like the science behind everything and
how it happened to actually realize okay
this kid actually has never taken
steroids this was an honest mistake
giving you silence quote it John Jones
is not a drug cheat this is negligence
he didn't realize it or whatever
but yeah a lot of people just they never
care to do the homework so so my image
was that I had taken a steroid and it
was the biggest hit because I had
literally spent sleepless nights you
know figuring out ways to get back in
the game and then to have it all taken
away with an honest mistake it was it
was terrible as there was something to I
had to really fight hard to get back
from but you know now we're here and
people don't understand what those with
the the pills like viagra cialis all
whatever they are we're in the
over-the-counter ones that sometimes I'm
like what do you need that for it's like
no sometimes it's just nice time I took
him a lot Mike you made myself stop
taking it good because for me it was
like I began to rely on them and I was
worthless without them though others um
I love those thanks so much so others
yeah but uh but they just give you a
little extra function without them no
absolutely your sinuses get messed up
I'm actually gonna have my sinuses check
- oh how many are you taking oh it was
back in 2003 when I went to Brazil with
my friends 100 milligrams it was ugly it
was ugly taking them like multivitamin
you're the really over the counter
hundred milligram viagra's whose bad
news my manager over there Wow but but
it does mess up your sinuses a little
bit I think on some level because I got
to go for the split I get that thing
that Cody grabbed breath there's a
balloon sinuplasty be here I said I
think I saw something a little bit about
it yeah I'm wondering part of it was
those pills do they make you so
congested to do this
yeah maybe a good fineness is and they
didn't affect you that like a hundred
milligrams yeah yeah yeah that's how I
knew was gonna be a good time when she's
on her way over my I can't breathe yeah
yeah it was money kids whenever when I
started to come out Jim was one of the
first guys to defend you because it's
like yeah that happens and of course he
would be taking them and because other
people who don't who aren't a part of
the culture world or whatever married
dudes or whatever they're like wow that
doesn't make any sense and Jim was like
it makes all the sense
well now you stop it with you like I
said yeah I'm engaged and I don't like
to do when I do take it my website or I
call them my wife yeah yeah episodes
happy to see me than that yeah free can
you
you have at it and then literally I
don't know from 20 minutes it's like it
never happened you're just ready to have
at it again yeah oh my god I mean you
want to keep your lady real happy
gentlemen absolutely and it just it just
makes you take away that pressure the
pressure of like all right is everything
gonna be okay like once that stays all
right that's handled for me I have a
different path than you I'm not an
athlete I'm in bad shape but I need to
work sorry right well liquidate good
good
are you ready to go again like like he
just like 20 minutes later key no I'm
not that's really smart company no I'm
done in time but the one is okay now
your stamina daddy you got some you know
I do list but it's only because I'm so
mentally messed up like I'm always in my
head about stuff and I don't know how to
focus on the real live moment favorable
I believe it's awful I was with a girl
in time and I looked I looked down and
she was like really like she's closing
your eyes which probably not to have to
look but I'm like how do you do that
like how do you just relax and enjoy a
moment I can't do it I have to read like
fueled by thoughts and craziness
you're more likely to lose an erection
than to come to quick yeah yeah yeah
yeah but those pills are for that
they're good numbers you know I'm sorry
for you like once you've done fighting
to be able to uh I'm fighting I'm trying
to get an endorsement deal right now
Sallis if you are listening yeah yeah
the baddest guy in the planet uses these
days yeah but it's excuse your a way to
get any of those that don't have that
one thing in there that was that was
just that one supplement that was
tainted or all them have that so we yeah
I trying to get into it too much but I
mean I'll briefly kind of explain how it
happened we we we amount to my teammates
gave me a pill he said hey John this
this stuff will run a girl's world right
so I took the pill and and ended up
getting tested by you SATA like three
days later I walk goes into my house
yeah where I have a seat bring about my
water bottles it was normal procedure
and come to find out before the fight
that I was drug tested and that vet drug
test periods before the fight the
results showed up closer to the fight
and manager called me over to his room
John you are fighting you failed a drug
test you have estrogen blockers in your
system at the time being a clean ethical
have been super outspoken
being a clean athlete what not steroids
anyways yeah I didn't get it and so I
had a lot of educating myself to do
about at what estrogen blockers even
were and so anyways long story short we
took all my supplements to a private lab
and super expensive we had them test
everything that I take and it took very
generic man I take like fish oil and
multivitamin protein everything very
normal thing but every man should try to
have in their diet you know for general
health and and so my manager said John
what is there anything that is just out
of the norm that you took and I was like
I had to think hard on as like you know
there was a sex bill so we took the sex
fell down you know we mailed it to a
private lab and and we ordered the
sexuals straight from the website and
had it delivered straight to the private
lab and the lab tested these pills and
what we've come to find out was there
were five ingredients listed on the
actual package of these pills and what
the lab found was seven ingredients in
the pill so there there are two things
in the pill that weren't advertised
which had you read to mute us all okay
that's no good right I can't take that
right so um so they sure enough and the
crazy thing about what the pills was we
we had several different packets of the
pills tested and the numbers were always
different so these two ingredients that
were not advertised and some pills there
would be really high doses and other
pills would be almost zero so what that
told us was that there the factory that
we're working with they're not cleaning
their material they're the machines
probably and so you know they're mixing
several different supplements on the
same machines and so you're geared
causing all your different supplements
that you sell to be somewhat
contaminated with things that are
advertised also weight that stuff wasn't
even in the pill it was more because
they all had the factory was not
cleaning the machine okay right right so
so that yes it makes perfect sense like
when you get a juice from one of these
trucks outside right and they use the
same blender every time and you depth if
you're allergic to strawberries you
better not use that right trying to fit
over your
so that's what happened and I'm grateful
that that you started dug so deep in to
admit you started the real deal yeah
they have their lawyers and just the way
they handle [ __ ] it was real and so I
was glad to go against them because what
they actually had to prove throughout
this whole process that is that it was
totally unintentional and there were
never any steroids involved and it was
an honest mistake but they had to punish
me because you know I didn't ask them
hey can I take this X pill and so they
said it was negligent for me to just
take a random sex okay
you know Mel enhancement without
checking what you thought at first you
know there's there's steps that we can
take to avoid any of this stuff from
happening and if I would have said hey
can I take this generic brand this you
know this uh cialis or this viagra
whatever they would say yes this is
clear of a bla but me I took some off
the collar off counter or whatever I
random ml enhancer pill and and I could
have avoided this whole situation by
just asking them for the okay how good
to this feel to be vindicated like in
the eyes of people who got I was a dumb
mistake but it was it wasn't a cheat how
great did that feel to have the proof
from them it felt amazing because I feel
like there's been athletes who smoke
marijuana or parties and throughout
history and you know it's definitely
frowned upon but it's forgivable
yeah I'm not amazed but but steroids and
you know every guy who's lost money
betting against you you know the little
kids who who see who thought that you
were just a super hard worker everything
just becomes be legitimized is just like
you never were this great that people
thought you were you know I mean were
like like party and it's like you this
guy can win while being a party animal
though but that's like he's a badass
yeah yeah but like steroids it's like
dude you're not a badass you've been
cheating and that you know it just it's
just the biggest insult to be looked at
as a steroid user so it was it was
phenomenal to have you side of themself
come out and say well you know it
definitely wasn't there is right
definitely wasn't on purpose it was
great to be free from that do you think
it hurts the potential of you doing a
Brock Lesnar fight because of what
happened
Brock Lesnar's fight with Mark Hunt when
he also they found estrogen blockers but
they I mean they didn't find out until
after the fight so they weren't going to
cancel the fight but the fact that
that's there and a lot of MMA fans we're
like oh that's what happened the pro
wrestler came in and he was all juiced
up and yeah Mark Hunt was pretty vocal
about a two-month oh yes yes yeah yeah
mark mark always let you know pretty
much how he feels he got furious yeah do
you think do you think that hurts like
the idea of this money fight happening
because MMA fans look at Brock
do you know Lee no no I think I don't
want to accuse breath of being on
anything but I would say and and his
sport I think fans almost expect that
and when you see these massive guys like
jumping off ropes and just like bugging
bodybuilding something like you you know
it's not talked about but everyone knows
how these guys are looking like that so
I don't think it will affect the fight
at all then people want to see this mess
and freak do what he does okay for there
to be a freak show every now and that
everyone every now and then I think as
long as he is clean by the time the
fight comes around which you thought it
will make sure of then I don't really
think the fans care what he's doing to
be the best Brock Lesnar in the WWF
arena I was shocked you called him out
because Brock to me is a you know I
think there's there's nobody in the
light heavyweight division you can't
beat and a lot of the heavyweights you
can be but he's a scary guy because he
just scary he puts you down and lays on
you and he's really good at keeping
people down yeah he's a big people save
all he's a pro wrestler but he was a
legitimate wrestler man and he held down
mark hunt mark hunt for three rounds and
Mark's a really strong guy I think I
think that's what makes the fight so
great is the legitimate danger there you
know I mean I mean people really could
see me losing that one and about them if
I'm not on my game it's a fight that
anything that happened what you just
said I mean he's a Division one wrestler
super athletic I mean he's no slouch I
mean look at him there's a there's not
any men on the planet that looks like
this guy so I and everybody that's ever
bought him whether it's MMA whether it's
pro wrestling whether it's amateur
wrestling like all anybody talks about
is how freakishly strong
he is like like inhumanly strong they
say there's a quote from a movies it's
the heart that makes it great yeah I
mean it being such a huge challenge is
what makes it great and and and that's
what I'm chasing I'm chasing greatness
and and this is this huge legacy thing
for me I need to be able to beat Brock
Lesnar's like do this guy truly is a bad
[ __ ]
we've already achieved greatness I mean
like you're you're legitimately looked
at as the is by far the best light
heavyweight and I would still put you as
the best fighter in UFC I know Demetrius
guess that and he's great but I think
that you beat some just whatever I would
put you above him
no but just because of the people you've
beaten I mean the gunfight resumes so it
says it all yeah and it's got to be hard
after a while thing okay well you've
beaten almost everybody in the light
heavyweight division so now you have to
to move up but the only problem is that
those guys a lot of those guys would
with the reach advantage might not be
there we need a guy like Brock has got
gigantic I don't know what his reaches I
imagine it's close to yours yeah um so
so I've heard that me and Stefan true
are the two guys with the longest reach
and it's crazy because he's almost 7
feet tall
arms to be as long as his I don't think
I would uh I don't think the reach would
be much different I think I would still
have the advantage of it most of them I
just think my presence wouldn't be one
had the same factor like when I'm out
there just being taller than these guys
and I just got a big frame you know so a
lot of times when they when they grab me
they feel like they're dealing with a
heavyweight yeah and I've grown up
Russell my older brother who was always
a heavyweight and most of my teammates
are that I go with our heavyweights so I
just have a very big presence about me
when I'm out there I've noticed you know
I just appear bigger than people and
heavyweight I think that that would be
gun you know no more because I just
clinch somebody up and just put them to
the floor and you make it look
effortless I would really have to be my
strength you had to be at all different
level my endurance would have to be in a
completely different level to fight
against these heavy weighs everything I
do would take double the energy and so I
would really have to be in tremendous
shape to compete against these guys
which at which I'm not afraid of trying
to do well that was what I was wondering
like when you call out a Brock Lesnar or
when you
it's just simply make that plan on going
into the heavyweight division do you do
it like with a strategy in mind like I
know I can train and this is how I would
be Brock Lesnar if he accepted this
fight or do you do it just knowing I'll
be able to come up with a strategy
before then yeah I felt like
stylistically Brock Lesnar is a very
winnable fight for us I mean the key to
the fight would have to be just just
really just kind of just using my
versatility on the feet and my speed and
then I have really good takedown defense
as well Gus has been you only got to get
me down and I was just completely caught
off guard and I wasn't expecting a
Swedish boxer to go away good completely
caught me off guard I don't think they
have wrestling over there in Sweden but
um but uh yeah it was a you know so yeah
the key for Brock is is literally to
just really stick and move and then to I
wouldn't be surprised if I got him down
you know I have a lot of unconventional
trips and takedowns that I but I pull
off my heavily so all the time and yeah
I wouldn't be surprised if I took down
Brock in and finish him up with a
submission and things like that and how
was it after the fight till I show you a
video at the rock that was a fun video
to watch had you met him before which
take it first time interact with it I
was my first time meeting the roster it
was such honor I have so many friends
that worship that man I mean he's like
he's like you say he's a true Idol yeah
so many people have so many different
ages and races and countries yeah I mean
he's like one of those he's like a
Michael Jackson like figure on the
planet like just loved by millions yeah
millions and millions of people and so
to meet him you really for me I felt
like I was in the presence of true
greatness this guy is so great and he
was just so kind and and one of my
favorite things about meeting
celebrities is when you meet ones that
are exactly the way they appear to be
and why you love run across the TV
screen yeah and he was that he was
everything that I was hoping that he'd
be just super genuine and just just a
nice guy it was honor to me
do you ever care who's in the in the
crowd when you're fighting
ever mean anything not to much as I've
gotten more seasoned as a fighter I've
learned to kind of embrace every ounce
of fighting so I'm literally looking
around to see what celebrities are there
and I'm waving to people I'm skiing in
the first few rows to see you know who I
know acknowledging everybody and stuff
like that and I'm glad to be that way
because it just shows my level of
comfort in the Octagon but but now I'm
never like more nervous because a
certain person is there no I did hear
Donald Trump was planning on coming to
this fight and I guess security reason
why is it wasn't you know wasn't going
to work out but I think that would added
a little nerve sure yes this is over the
city yes president yeah oh yeah yeah
that would've been cool coming to New
York too
they said he might come to New York
Garden Show yeah we had heard that I
think if somebody I remember that yeah
but the security to get any he was I was
at the only boxing match I've ever gone
to is I saw golovkin fight and Trump was
in the row ahead of us say four sheets
down but he was still running so he had
Secret Service but he wasn't the
president now forget it
yeah I'm can't put the president in a
little bit of Reena yeah no I know where
to me holes distribute yelling even
people that was just yelling and
screaming his breath yeah a big
distraction for sure um what uh what GGG
who was he fighting I don't remember the
guys name actually I'm not a big boxing
fan at all Louie CK called me the night
before he was what are you doing
tomorrow yeah I'm like nothing is you
wanna go see a boxing match so I just
met Lilly and II went to the fight I
forget who he was fighting to Beyonce
mr. Taylor
yeah I like him a lot but I don't very
rarely watch boxing I just I stopped
years ago because of MMA I just enjoy it
much more what's your prediction with
Mayweather Gregor I'm a waiter and it's
not because I don't like McCoy I never
liked McGregor because you beats up
people I like like I like a girlfriend
or honest yeah but I mean I did on your
show though no I think he's great I mean
the guy's a great fighter that suck in
second Diaz fight the fact that he lost
and then came back and won a five round
decision he was incredible you guys but
he's phenomenal so I would love to see
him beat Floyd Mayweather because I like
him a lot more than I like Floyd I'm not
a big fan even though I respect him so I
would like to see McGregor beat him but
he I just don't think you can commit a
beating best defensive fighter ever what
is it about
boy you know I've interviewed him once
and he wasn't unpleasant but he was a
bit standoffish and normally that's how
I judge people is how they are when I
talk to them and he wasn't he spoke but
that's way too Jewish
oh yeah it was like I can only actually
met him and that like oh right right
yeah I would hate someone that they've
never met but come on guys I read an
article about him I can't say anything
right yeah we had him on and he came in
and again I know he's four but he came
in with like really gigantic bodyguards
and like you don't you don't need all
that he kept his sunglasses on I'm like
Floyd which is promoting a big show
ready he wasn't awful but he could have
been a little bit looser like you know
Tyson comes in by himself or with a
buddy or is it with his wife like he
doesn't need guys you know I just prefer
that makes sense it makes just like I
was telling you like one of the best is
what meeting celebrities when they when
they're being a human being yeah yeah
when the real right what did you did you
decide to switch up how you dress like
coming because I kind of noticed it like
looking at like interviews you're doing
leading up to the fight and then after
the fight like it seemed like you are
consciously trying to portray something
different like a little more mature a
little more like you know put together
yeah yeah I think it's important for me
to obvious I'm not like like a super
fancy like suit guy or whatever but I
think that's important for me to try to
you know represent myself as
professional especially because of my
history right I think you know a lot of
people may kind of look at me as being a
little bit of a you know thug or whatnot
and so I just make sure I put a little
bit more thought into the way I carry
myself in present myself I know that I'm
trying to rebrand myself and create a
new a new beginning a new image you
things like that so I just think we're
looking like a young man it's important
it's important you for a role model
model perspective too because especially
it's like a famous black man like
there's not that many great male black
role models people talk about all the
time are you saying I know Sam hey I'm
gonna [ __ ] you up
yeah what I would do is I would smack
him know that you let what mirror pieces
it really there's a really good
structure do you feel the pressure
because a lot of my people will say like
hey you're black roller Molly do you
feel any pressure to to behave a certain
way
that pressure put on you um you're
welcome Sam by the way for you thank you
I was getting there oh I don't really
look at it is a black and white thing I
just think I just think you know like my
kids are half white and everything like
that a lot of my friends are spanic
Wayne so I really trying to look through
those of color I just think it's
important as an athlete to to I realized
that we have a platform and that we can
actually inspire a lot of people and we
can also lead people down the wrong path
and I feel like I feel like for a while
there I let a lot of people down the
wrong the wrong path you know I've had
fighters say things to me like oh dude
if you can drink before a fight
they're not you're not then I'll drink
before I could do it too you know so I
just feel like like I've done a good job
not being the best example and and so at
this point I'm really ready to to try to
inspire people through my life so I'm a
lot already feel pressure for being like
a black athlete or whatever I just feel
I just feel like with great gifts and
talents going great responsibility and I
and I have to try to do try to do right
for the most part because I understand
that people are watching I understand
that I've been a bad example for a lot
of athletes if there's of that so it's
time for me to get some of that back and
show people that you know rocky
beginnings doesn't necessarily have to
be the whole shirt no Travis is telling
us we have to wrap up some guessing
that's coming they have two other press
yeah go to sway okay um yeah and just I
think the thing is people love the fact
and just in closing that everyone likes
a good turn around you know and and the
fact that being flawed is okay like
having [ __ ] up is okay it's like it's
not a sign of weakness it's like a who
is 23 champion of the world wouldn't
make some mistakes
now you're 30 you got out of your system
it's like you say that years or fight
it's great people people do they loved
it they loved to boost somebody up
they'd love to tear them down and then a
few people that are like strong enough
to actually then be able to be the
redemption story because most people
after the teardown
yeah but like if you can get yourself
back up there then I think people will
like they love that forever
yeah you know I just feel like my
situation is just so relatable and so
it's been it's been a blessing and a
curse
I think I think that's been a main
problem with Daniel Cormier just to
constantly you know tell people I don't
you know I don't wrecked my car I don't
do this little party bit about it's like
Daniel there's just so many more people
who's made mistakes in their life you
know I mean everybody's dealing with
some type of demon one way or another
and so to try to market yourself as this
this perfect person it's just it's just
so unrelatable and so with all my
struggling on my um all the [ __ ] that
I've been through man it's been great
because I hear people all the time tell
me like John you have no clue how bad I
just dropped out of school hey I just
got my girlfriend pregnant or hey I just
I had this you know and this is like I
was so inspired to know that my life
isn't over because of all the [ __ ] you
just got through right you know so it's
great to be a testimony a living
testimony that people can draw strength
from it really is